bon et pas de jugement il y en a ils ont
des animaux de compagnie en raison des
chiens et en raison des chaleurs les
ondes et des cochons d'inde et hamsters
et là jérémy qui vient de chez moi dans
l'aisne il a un faisan c'est un drôle de
but 0 2 guignicourt donc ré c'est ton
animal de compagnie exactement ça
faisant quoi
il s'appelle qui s'appelle comment vu du
tout où tu te rends compte que tu lâches
des roues aux travaux du 12e l'a acheté
parce que ça me faisait plaisir d'avoir
à présent c'est un peu original et voilà
vous êtes pompiste et froide river au
télétravail en jeu c'est quoi ton rire
moi
le mal des transports c'est très simple
pour que le cerveau comprennent dans
quelle position vous aide dans l'espace
il a besoin de trois informations une
qui vient des yeux une qui vient d
oreille interne et une qui vient des
récepteurs qui se trouvent notamment
sous nos pieds si une des trois infos
correspond pas aux deux autres paf c'est
mal des transports et vous avez la
nausée et envie de vomir et c'est ce qui
se passe par exemple quand vous lisez en
voiture parce que vous lisez ça c'est
plutôt fixe mais votre oreille interne
et voit bien que vous tourner dans les
virages en montagne et comprend pas donc
elle envoie la formation au cerveau qui
disjoncte et c'est ça le mal des
transports alors pour le prévenir ben on
lit pas en voiture et si vous êtes en
bateau vous regarder l'horizon il faut
toujours un point fixe pour que le
cerveau est un repère pour bien
comprendre les infos qu'il a
pourquoi les belges cours autour des
écoles
ainsi poursuivre leurs études
c'est pourquoi c'est les chats qui capte
le mieux non parce qu'il y en a 4 g
c'est pourquoi les djihadistes et sont
souvent fiers d'eux ce qu'ils se bomber
le torse
[Applaudissements]
enzo tu vois les pompiers ils font pas
pompeux et bats-toi c'est quand que tu
me paies pomper pompe billy du range tes
jouets
je te lis pas d'histoire tu ranges
déjouer
billy si tu ranges pas tes jouets jeux
t'oblige à manger un oeuf kinder
[Musique]